hi everyone
welcome to the fifth tutorial in our
imaging science series
my name is brian murnoff i'm the
education coordinator at the mit museum
and today we're going to be exploring
how to use the light around you to
improve your photography so whether
that's a light source such as
a flash or a flashlight or the light on
your phone
or ambient light from a light in the
room or sunlight
how can you take advantage of that to
take some
really interesting photos the first
thing that we're going to look at is how
do you control
the ambient light ambient light is just
the light
around you so what's the light that's
already in the room that you're not
producing
um using a flashlight or anything that
you have on you
and how do you how do you adjust
that light to appear how you want so
we're going to be using our exposure
triangle for this
and so the first example i'll show you
is let's say
i don't want to see any background in my
photo
so i only want to see light that's
coming from in this case
the light from a camera flash
so what i'm going to do is adjust my
settings so that if i take the picture
this picture on the left here without
turning on the light source
it's pretty much completely black
if my light is completely black then
when i turn on the flash only the things
that the flash hits
are going to be lit up in my image so
you can't see
any of the background here really
anything at all until i take the same
picture with the same
settings with the flash turned on and
you can adjust this using your iso your
shutter speed your aperture
it doesn't matter really which one and
just like we talked about in previous
videos
you'll adjust your settings based on
what other effects you want in your
video
now if i take the same picture but this
time i want to see in the lower right
here i want to see the background i want
to see the wall
behind tim the beaver what i'm going to
do is in my
test shot before i add any light
to my image i'm going to adjust my
settings adjust my exposure triangle
so i can see the background in the way
that i want it to appear
close to how i want it to appear in the
final image
so now in the lower left you can see
that you can see the wall you can see
the color of the wall
so when i turn on the flash it'll
brighten that wall a little bit
most of the light will fall on tim the
beaver here in the lower right
but you'll get to see the background so
before you start
using um additional lights and lamps and
light sources
you want to take that test photo to get
the exposure just from the light that's
around you
so when we talk about light in
photography there are two main
types of light we call these hard light
and soft light now on the left side of
the image here you can see
the hard light hard light usually comes
from a
small source so where the light's coming
from is very small but it's also very
bright
and so when you shine this light such as
the light coming from this lamp on your
subject
you get very bright spots on your
subject
as well as very dark shadows on your
subject
so you can kind of see in the second
picture from the left here that
the beaver almost looks like he has a
spotlight on him there's this bright
light that's
clearly coming from a specific direction
from the left here
and the right side of him is in shadow
on soft light on the other hand the
light is more dispersed
it's bouncing around the room it's
coming from lots of different directions
so in this case on the right you can see
that the beaver is now being
lit by this lamp and some of the lights
coming directly from the lamp
down to the beaver and some of it's
going to the ceiling or walls bouncing
around
and then hitting the subject so now in
this picture
on the second one here you can see that
the entire image
is lit up and all the shadows are filled
in
and you get a very good picture of the
entire subject
you're going to want to choose whether
you're going to use hard or soft light
depending on your subject and depending
on what you want to show
so we're going to look at some
properties of both
so first let's explore hard light
so hard light is really good at
emphasizing certain parts of your photo
so highlighting
very specific regions and then hiding
the stuff
that you don't want to see so in the
upper left here
we have the beaver lit from actually
underneath his face is kind of that
scary campfire
look um that you get when you're sitting
around the campfire telling scary
stories it causes these really kind of
creepy shadows where his
his eyes would be here um in the next
photo the top middle here we're lighting
him directly from above so
now we're able to see more of him but
his shirt isn't as highlighted
um but his nose is very clearly seen
in the next one the top right um he's
highlighted again from the top kind of
from an angle and you can see how we get
these long shadows on the ground that
might be an effect that you want
it may not and so you can change those
shadows by changing
where that light is coming from
on the bottom left here um we have an
anteater
um looking at its next meal and um this
is taken
outside and usually don't think about it
because the sun is so bright but
the sun is a type of hard light the
light's coming from a specific point in
the sky
it's really really bright so it has a
very similar effect to
using a lamp a light bulb from a lamp or
a flashlight
and what that causes is you can see this
very dark shadow
coming off of the anteater so the light
is
all coming from a direction in this case
it's coming from kind of behind and to
the left of the anteater
and it causes hard shadows here so when
we talk about bright sunlight that's
also going to be hard light
in the last two examples in the center
bottom and right bottom here
we have examples of backlighting so
instead of placing the light in front of
the subject
you can place the light in back and what
that does is it creates this really
nice silhouette effect around your
subject
that may be what you're going for maybe
the shape of your
your subject is the important part if it
is
backlighting is a great way to highlight
that while hiding some of the other
features that may not be as important
in the lower right you can actually
combine different types of light so if
you have multiple light
lights you can combine the effects so i
have
the backlight in this image just like
the one before
but i've also added a flashlight from
underneath in front
so you get the silhouette of tim the
beaver and you also get to see
some of his face and it gives a little
kind of again that campfire creepy look
um but also while out outlining him
backlight also has a really um cool use
um in showing the again the outlines of
things but being able to see
through things that are very thin so
this is something i highly recommend
trying is either go outside or just look
around your house and find something
that's made out of a thin material or
that has spaces in it
something with some negative space and
when you use backlight
you get to see those empty spaces or
those thinner spaces in a lot more
detail
so in the first image to the left here
we have a close-up of a leaf
this is actually just being backlit by
the sun again the sun is a type of hard
light
and you can see all of the veins in the
leafs in the pattern
between the structure of the leaf
in the center picture it's a similar
technique except this was taken
with a flash underneath the beneath the
leaf
so you get a different look the sun is
going to be a larger light source than
a smaller camera flash that's placed
behind
so you get this kind of brightness
grading throughout the image the center
is really bright
and it falls off towards the edges it
gets darker
and then on the right by backlighting
this picture of
this curled up fern you can see
the edges of those fern leafs much more
clearly than you
would without the backlight so the
lights coming through you see those
negative spaces and you see the edges
and the hairs and all the details
you can even see in the bottom of this
the
some of the leaf patterns the the vein
patterns in the fern leafs that have
already
unfurled as mentioned before
hard light can also be used to create
shadows
so you may want to strategically
position shadows
in your image so in this video below
as i move the flashlight around closer
to the object farther at different
angles and around
you can see how that shadow moves and no
matter what light source you're using
whether it's a flashlight that's always
on
a lamp a flash gun you're going to
create
the same types of shadows based on where
you position the light
so this is a great way just using a
flashlight to see okay when i turn on my
camera
flash this is the shadow pattern that
i'm going to see around my object and
this is what's going to be in the
highlights
so hard light is great if you want
really bright light highlight certain
parts of your image create dramatic
shadows control the angle of the light
but what if you want to
show the whole object if you want to
display the entire subject you want the
background
to be in your image so in that case
you're going to want to use
soft light so how do you create
soft light because most light sources
are going to be
hard right light is going to be produced
from a small source it's going to be
very
bright so we're going to want to figure
out how do you take
an image with hard light change the
light
by modifying it just a little bit to
give you soft light
that lights every part of your subject
so
the first technique that i'll show you
to do this the simplest technique is
move the light farther away so light
spreads out as it moves away from its
source so you can see in this flashlight
on the left when it's close to the stool
it creates a pretty small
spot that's very bright on on the stool
in the next one the flashlight we've
moved it a bit farther away
and the spot gets bigger it also gets a
little bit dimmer you can start seeing
some of the grain of the wood
where the light's hitting and the third
one to the right we've
moved the flashlight very far away from
the stool
it's lit up the stool but now the entire
stool is in frame
and for the most part you can see all
the grain so
the the light has lost some of its
brightness as well as
spread out in addition to moving the
light away
you can also try bouncing the light so
instead of for example with a camera
flash
so in the leftmost image here we have
light that's going to go directly
from the flash to the subject and that's
going to be a very
hard light very bright and hard light
or instead of directing it straight
towards the subject
in the second image we can point the
flash straight up to the ceiling
now when that light instead of now going
directly to the subject
goes up to the ceiling spreads out
and then lights the entire subject
evenly
so by bouncing the light instead of
sending it straight towards your subject
that can help in creating softer light
if you don't have a flash for your
camera or using a cell phone
another thing you can do is use a piece
of paper
so i recommend white paper because
that's going to reflect
most of the light and what i'm doing
here is
lighting this dragon you can actually
see it the light
you can see how much brighter the front
of the dragon is compared to the rest of
the stool
and what's happening here is the
flashlight is bouncing
off of this paper and then spreading out
and hitting the dragon so if you don't
have
a ceiling close by if your ceiling is
really high up or if it's a darker color
you may want to use a piece of paper and
if you don't have a flash use a
flashlight and it works
just as well we can also
modify our flash or our lights in order
to
spread out the light and these are
called
diffusers and diffusers just it's
something that the light passes
through so that it spreads out before
hitting your
subject so there are ones that you can
put on here like in the second image to
the left here
just plastic pieces that can go on a
camera flash or
you don't have that just use a piece of
paper so in the third image here we have
just a piece of paper taped to the front
of the flash and now
the light from the flash has to pass
through that paper and spread out
before hitting our subject if you want
to aim that light a little bit more
just change the shape of the paper so in
this last image to the right here
we have the paper curled around the
flash and so now when the light comes
out it's going to bounce off this paper
and then
be bounced forward towards the subject
in front of the camera
we can also do this with lamps so a
simple way to turn
a lamp light into a more diffused light
is something that the lamp probably
already has is a shade
so instead of pointing the lamp directly
at your subject
have the light that hits your subject
come from the side of the lamp where the
light is has to pass through the
lampshade
before hitting the subject you can also
use the same paper techniques on the
bottom right here
i've taped a piece of paper right in
front of that lamp
and that spreads out the light so much
more
of the subject has light falling on him
rather than just that one spot that we
had before we added that piece of paper
so now that you can control hard light
and soft light and turn hard light into
soft light
let's look at another factor that can
greatly change
what your image looks like and this is
the background so you can change the
background
of your image and that's going to have a
large effect on how the light
bounces off of your subject
so in this first example i have the
dragon here and instead of shining light
directly onto the dragon
i'm shooting the light into the mirror
and then from the mirror
it's hitting the dragon and you can see
that you get in this case i'm using a
flat
uh camera flash so it has a rectangular
shape
and that mirror is going to concentrate
that light just on that one spot
so by using a mirror i reflect light
it's not really going to spread out that
much but i can highlight a very specific
portion of my subject
now if instead of a mirror what if i put
something
black as my background so here i just
have a black
box and again i'm shining the light
from the left side of my image so the
lights coming from kind of the lower
left here
and instead of hitting the dragon first
it goes to the box
and bounces back now to see what this
black box is actually doing
let's compare it with an image with a
white background
so in this third picture i've switched
out the background for a white piece of
paper
now when the light comes in it hits that
paper
reflects and spreads out and you can see
how this allows the entire
subject to be lit where when we have the
black background
only part of the subject basically where
the light happens to hit the dragon
before bouncing into the black
background
is lit up and this is because black
when the color black is formed from
reflected light
it's formed because that surface is
absorbing a lot of that light
very little light is bouncing off when
you see white
white when caused by reflected light is
caused when
all of the colors of light bounce off
that
surface and it looks white to your eye
so because white reflects light
the light bounces off that hits the
subject and we get a very
bright image if we use a black
background it's going to absorb that
light
and keep those shadows on the subject
and if you use something very reflective
like a mirror and this is going to
change a little bit depending on the
shape of the mirror
you can control exactly where that
reflected light
falls we can also play around with a
similar effect by changing the surface
um that your subject is on
so here i've taken a picture with the
exact same setup same
lighting of this glass turtle on white
paper
a wooden table and a black background
and you can see there's some dramatic
differences in these pictures even
though the light source
in this case a hard light is the same
so when i use a white background this is
going to reflect a lot of light so you
can see
that light is kind of scattering within
the clear parts
of our image these the clear parts of
the turtle are actually very bright
you can see the shadow of the turtle you
can actually see some of the color
from the light that's passing through
parts of the turtle those colors are on
that background
when i use the wood background because
that doesn't reflect as much light
we still get a shadow not as much
light now though is passing through so
the clear parts of
our turtle are actually appearing a bit
darker which is making some of the color
stand out a little bit more
but because it's not so reflective we
don't actually see any of the color
in the shadow from the turtle
and the last image here on the right
we're using a black background now the
black background absorbs light
it's also hiding the shadow so maybe i
don't want shadow in my image
so this is going to hide that it's also
going to absorb that light so we're not
getting light
bouncing back through so you can see
you get a lot less glare as the light
passes
back through the clear parts of the
turtle because the light isn't passing
back through you're actually seeing some
higher contrast between the clear
parts of the glass and the color parts
and those colors
really stand out so now what if you're
outside the sun is really bright and you
don't have another light source
well you can still control the light
that's bouncing off your subject and the
way you're going to do that is
decide on what time of day you're going
to shoot
so for example here are two images
taken arches national park and
they have very different colors and very
different lighting situations
the picture on the left was taken in the
middle of the day
the sun was really bright in the sky
it's acting like
hard light and everything is just bright
there's very little contrast meaning
everything is just kind of the same
brightness in the image there really
aren't any
dark areas if there were there would be
very dark shadows but it's very just
it's bright or it's really dark
on the right side of the image this
image was taken
near sunset and this is what's called
golden hour golden hour is either
right around sunset or right around
sunrise
when the sun is at a very low angle in
the sky
when this happens the light has to
scatter in the atmosphere the light
from the sun travels through the
atmosphere and has to spread out over a
farther distance
so not only do you get a softer light so
you can see things in the image aren't
just as bright um as in the image on the
left
but we also get some colors is that
light refracts through the atmosphere
we're getting the light separating and
we get much
more color out of her image we're
getting this reddish color
and we also see not just things that are
really bright
or really dark but we also have kind of
everything in between here
in this bottom set of images we have
the same picture taken at not just three
different times of day
but also different weather conditions
the first one on the left here
this was taken in the middle of the day
so again really hard light so things are
either really bright
or really dark if they're in shadow
in the second picture in the middle it
was really cloudy and what clouds do
is they act just like the diffusers that
we talked about earlier
so now the light from the sun has to
pass through the clouds
it bounces around it spreads out and we
get much more
even lighting and you can see
things aren't all the same brightness
now we can actually see a lot of the
colors starting to come out we have
dark blues and greens and browns in this
image because the light
is much softer in the third image on the
right
this was taken in same location but
closer to sunset near golden hour
again you can see the higher contrast so
lots of different colors lots of
different brightness
and the more of the reddish tint as the
sun refracts through the atmosphere
now taking pictures of the same subject
at different times of day
this doesn't just work for for
landscapes
but it also can really help for close-up
photos
so here isn't two different images of
lichen on a tree one of them the one on
the left was taken in the middle of the
day so we had really hard light from the
sun
and that just makes everything really
really bright
the one on the right was taken during
golden hour so taken near sunset
the light is much softer we have a much
bigger range of contrast so things are
bright
dark and in the middle and this lets us
see a lot more
detail in our subjects if you look
closely
you can see all the little kind of
spikes and nodules coming out of the
lichen on the image on the right
where the image on the left is much
harder to see so everything kind of
blends together
when everything is just lit at the same
brightness
thank you for joining us for this
tutorial in our imaging
science series with the mit museum and
coke institute
we'd love to see your stunning science
photos if you'd like to share them with
us you can share them on facebook
twitter and instagram and use the
mitm imaging science to share those with
us
at the end of this program so on june
20th we'll be holding a webinar
to look at what makes a great science
photo
and some of the so submissions have a
chance to
be featured during that webinar
for more information on the imaging
science program
other tutorials and other information
and resources
please visit the mit museum website at
the link below
and you will find a list of our other
resources as part of the imaging science
program